all right let's do uh EO from katata
Dori we have Ura as
well
and we'll switch
[Music]
rolls
okay have one more
OT do EO though
okay
yeah
okay all
right
uh
okay so the
problem is that or we think the problem
problem is that there's mistakes being
made and UK has an opportunity to fix
the person okay and the second mistake
is that the best way of fixing the nag
is to resist the nagas technique okay to
expose its openings so to speak okay but
this is an extension of the idea that
kihon waza is in some way of Martial
engagement and it's not
okay but pedagogically the logic is
unsound so UK cannot learn
anything if they are stopped before they
do the move do you see if you're going
to say that's wrong that's wrong that's
wrong so let's say for
[Music]
example we're going to do a simple math
math problem okay got it and you're I'm
going to say what is 2 + 2 that's
wrong 3 + 2 that's
wrong 3 +
3 okay got one right okay 4 + three
that's
wrong they're never going to get good at
math you see I'm never letting them get
it okay to learn something then you have
to do something okay so you're not
helping them by shutting them down by
making them
martially potent this is not the place
for them okay you have to do gazi you
have to do Spar you have to train in the
expanded curriculum Kea is not the place
for that but even if it was
pedagogically this is unsound they will
never get better if you keep shutting
them
down
part of the problem is not only a
misunderstanding of what kihon waza is
part of the problem is that there's no
more
Sensei modern iido has gotten rid of
Sensei and what's in its place is a
class Runner person a class leader so if
you look on the mat everybody steps a
certain way their own way everyone moves
their arms their own way everyone puts
their weight in their own
place there's no way you're learning the
art there are
energetic
requirements they themselves
require biomechanical
requirements they themselves require
kinesiological requirements it is not a
freefor all there's not one way to
move and then another way to move it
doesn't matter on your height either
they always do that I got my own I'm
taller than you I'm shorter than you no
it doesn't matter it does not matter if
you look at my technique it never
changes different height different size
of the UK does not change anything
there's even
technique where I'm doing shag from
suaza and we're both in suara so give me
a break it's it's not a technique for
when you're shorter than a god
no you don't you're not doing it right
that's the problem
okay but when you have a class leader
the class leader just introdu introduces
the technique and then everyone does
what they're going to do and if if I may
if I may interrupt on you I'll show you
a little
tip but that tip itself is based upon my
own personal preference that maybe had a
tip that my instructor showed me but
there's no sound principle to it
okay so because there's no actual
teacher there's just a class leader who
might give you a tip but it doesn't
really matter because everyone does
their own thing
anyways what the hell is my
tip it looks like you're left alone as
no as nogget you see and so now UK has
got to come and fix you and I say
UK's got to worry about their
own skill development
and Naga has to worry about their own
skill development and both of them are
the teacher responsibility so this is
one reason why when you're a trial
member you call me Dave you don't call
me Sensei all you in patreon land you
call me Dave don't call me Sensei
because I am not committed to you the
word Sensei means I have made myself
responsible for your own
betterment
you guys are have not committed to that
level so why would I commit back I'm
just
Dave if you're allowed to join the dojo
the first thing comes out of my mouth is
you will refer to me as Sensei always at
all times it's going to be weird hello
this is Sensei yes no cuz they're not my
suited right so what I tell you this is
day valid is okay but you send me a text
you send me an email you're going to say
Sensei you're never going to say hey
you're not going to say nothing you're
not going to say Dave otherwise let's
not get married M go away okay because
the commitment is way more work got it
so you're my job so as you come up and
you come up I already saw all the things
okay you're heel
lady your your arm moves independently
of your Center your shoulder dependent
you have a weakness in your shoulder
okay you
walk double
weighted when you ten
con you twist it it's not going to work
okay if I want to fix
you I will get more out of it or more
out of You by just telling you how to
move okay so let's take EO
or there it is right
there well you do the exact same thing
because I don't know if the camera
caught so don't change
it you changed
it
now enter
that that step which is I guarantee you
most of you do it that step does not
work okay what she is going to do is
she's going to create rotational energy
on him here you do you understand
okay
but there will be the equal and opposite
energy coming back through
here and she has no base of support
here do you see so let me in and I'll
show you what I mean
please here is where your righteous
helping
UK is going to feel
no
no that we going to
work but she didn't learn
anything
okay so what you have to
[Music]
do is get yourself
there in
turn single pivot on that one foot on
this
foot
here boom boom single
pivot then you follow him down he's
falling stay up
with so we would do a drill the teacher
would do a drill
we're just going to
enter single
pivot
enter single pivot
enter single pivot and now I'm working
on her do you got
it or we would do a micro drill of the
technique we pull out that one
part go ahead and get there who cares
it's not a marshal
engagement and now take that last drill
enter single
pivot you're going to enter single pivot
one get
there boom single to
it and then we get
better okay do the whole technique from
there or maybe just do
the C
part enter single pivot throw them
down another micro drill boom one two
throw them
down when you can do that follow Down
single PIV throw them down follow them
down you guys see that this is how you
make someone better shutting them
down will never ever go go go is never
going to help her discover what she's
supposed to do okay you
won't so let's do the
drills okay doing drill one keep
going breathe
out your feet will come together
your feet come together enter feet
together enter turn feet
together okay drill
two you're in the
technique just game the entry
part and enter and single
pivot
enter single
pivot you can't prematurely turn enter
and then single pivot just game that
part nope right foot is going to
move right foot single pivot there you
go do that side again so I have you do
the side cuz you could see it's not
familiar with your body right so I'm not
going to make you switch sides let's get
one side
first
good I don't care what you do with the
hand workk do you
understand just game it Virginia lean
over Virginia
stop stop
Taylor so again I am the teacher on the
math and my UK is jacking up my beginner
I control my UK
too got it stay
there inter and turn there you
go enter and
turn Okay
continue
no throwing down just entering and
turning no
projecting you're going to enter and
turn on that entering
foot enter left foot turn on
it
[Music]
you're going to turn your hips don't
just step into place you're not just
twisting your
[Music]
feet turn there you
go you close the qua you close the
homolateral
qua nope start gaming the wrist we're
not doing the technique put the hand on
your other
hand
there you go and now enter single pivot
you NOP nope try it
again turn there you go you can hold the
elbow other
side hold the elbow
Margaret enter pivot good hold the elbow
now I'm not going to say it a third time
right he try it
[Music]
again hold the
elbow hold the elbow enter and
turn bring him with you when you turn
yes again same
side intern turn there you go again same
side intern turn good drill
three inter turn project down let him go
go make sure you're turning and
projecting down turn project
down enter turn
project turn turn your qua don't just
step your feet turn your qua turn your
[Music]
qua turn your quaw keep your feet under
your
hips
okay so C uh couple things already
different from normal IO we're old as
one there's a
teacher the teacher got to be at a
minimum like an actual coach and an
actual coach has a way to do it don't
want to do it get off my team it's that
simple
okay second thing is your coach ain't
going to take your crap for long you see
that that's not acceptable another Dojo
they don't they let you keep with your
ego your ego attachment your self
identity your comfort SS they want to
leave you there so you don't transform
why because it's easier
it's easier to be a class leader than it
is to be a
teacher it's that
simple so coaches are going to take your
crap for very long right okay they're
going to help you get over you at a
minimum any coach with their salt is
going to do that class leaders don't all
right now we have built these micr
drills over the problems that the
Contemporary UK wants to somehow teach
you by not letting you do
them we built micro drills instead and
we put that responsibility of building
them and utilizing them on the teacher
okay and as we're working them we're not
going to take your crap you're going to
get these down and then we'll give you
some other tips to work it out cuz maybe
the understanding is not there okay so
for example get there however you want
as I demonstrated that I'm I'm trying to
free your minds to get out of
EO you see some of you don't know EO
well and you can't get to the micr drill
because you can't figure this part out
so I demonstrated it like this let go of
EO we're not doing EO right now we're
doing a mechanical drill and I want to
now fine-tune an aspect of it and I'm
not going to
enter and step it's not a matter of
moving my feet
it's a matter of my qua moving do you
see so when I enter and I single pivot
this qua is going to close and this is
me fine-tuning your micro drill so I
single pivot and that qua
closes it is
not that I step and then close my CLW it
happens on the
rotation I'm moving
in
is when I close the claw but I have the
intention of closing this
see okay let's try it again
go now we do the fourth drill where I do
everything I've done up till now but as
they start to descend I stay up with
them okay go fourth micro
drill
for
turn the front
foot and stay
up so now as I'm watching the
dasi and I watch you go again do that
same
side I will be looking for what
rationale was in the person's mind that
set up the body movement keep going and
I I draw my attention to a particular
thing the elbow comes down at the end
the shoulder comes down at the end okay
stop what this is
about is a very common
misunderstanding and that is that you
use your weight to get them
down we don't we're not going to use our
weight I'm not using my weight to get
him down I'm not trying to overpower
him uh a side note just cuz I saw one of
these recently and the guy was saying
how to do this stuff do you see and then
they going to kneel
down you guys see
that one that is scary as hell on my
back leg hopefully that person doesn't
land on my back leg but it is clear that
this turn I'm never going to make on
someone resisting me as we saw there but
you can see in its
intention it's using weight to drop down
and I am suggesting something else
I am throwing him
down so when I come around I'm
projecting this
down he's going down I don't need any
weight on
there what makes it look like I used my
weight is as I projected him boom I
stayed up with the
projection so he should already be all
the way down w boom
pop and I stay up with
it he should not
be part way
down then I use my
weight nor should he be shoulder
out and then I use my
weight this is what you're
doing
instead oh I down boom and I stay up
with
it you get it I'm not using my weight to
use my weight I'd have to weigh enough
that I could actually force him
down well some people yes bigger heavier
people no okay so let's clean that up
I'm addressing the mindset of the
dase as it is embodied in their
deviation from the correct form okay
here we here we
[Music]
go
throw him down don't just spin him throw
him down when you rotate throw him
down throw him down stay up there you
go
better
[Music]
turn don't start slurring the moves give
each move diction complete each cycle of
action turn throw follow turn throw
follow turn throw turn fully throw fully
follow turn throw follow there you go
all
right now we got the micro drill going
let us with these elements return back
to the drill I back to the waza okay at
a minimum I as an instructor has set up
a common
nomenclature complete with details on I
can now correct you on the Fly got it
okay let's
go full
technique
go nope don't start like that anymore
Taylor throw
follow no weight on The
Descent
no weight on The Descent you're short
changing the Turning
turn turn throw
better
get your other hand in the fight start
over no bad
reps other hand in the
fight enter turn good sit on your
heels drop your
weight no weight on The
Descent you have to turn more and
project
more better you don't need to fall this
to stay up if you start on time you
don't need to raise to catch
up boom better there you
go all right and now I would have the
Desi continue that over and over and
over until it becomes actually familiar
to their body until that way is more
what their body recognizes as opposed to
all those other ways you did so my
expectation at this point is if we were
to increase the stress so for example
all right you guys can come in with
anything and I want to see EO Ura your
ability to tap into the what you just
did is not going to be there okay I
would also expect a uh performance
degradation over time so if we don't
touch this technique for two weeks you
going to go back to the old way do do
you see that so you have to keep working
and you'll get rid of a lot of stuff
with just familiarity with exposure to
it hence the uh protocol for daily
training okay it just works out that way
um and any other of all the errors that
you saw there the heel weighted the
double pivot the double weighted all
that kind of stuff I would address as we
always do here with micro drills and it
would be the teacher's job to address
those things there is no way in a
million years that an UK that would shut
you down on let's say just EO Ora
there's no way in a million years by
being shut down from your double pivot
would you ever learn how to single pivot
project close the qua and follow them
down not using your weight to that you
would never discover that okay again
that would be like again if you go
deeper evolutionary theory which patreon
group I've asked you to let go of
because it is just
no amount of Chance is going to
make a 747 no matter matter how long you
wait for it it's never going to show up
in the middle of a junk pile okay so
correct form is never going to show up
because I'm trying to adapt your
Technique by selecting against crap a
good form is never going to show up from
that all that happens is that you just
suck and you just stay where you are
okay here's something else to note I
guarantee you that overwhelmingly about
80 to 90% of the people on in the
patreon Community are not doing Eco Ura
like you just saw and in fact are using
that double pivot with that crossover or
some other weight
dropping um mechanism again does not
work it only works because yuk was not
strong enough to
reveal the conflict in between
centrifugal and cental forces that are
working against the shikaku in your base
of support the dead angle
okay all
right let me have uh Andrew film
Andrew's okay so all that fixing of the
UK is a teachers job and this is not
only the best way of them learning
but at the very beginning even at this
physical component level of training
which is what it is there's no point
going into the energetic component if we
can't get the physical component first
okay and definitely there's no spiritual
training here we are not there yet
okay but it is the teacher's job to
address
that but it is the best way of
addressing it okay okay right I'm I'm
not the teacher what should I do got got
that question question what should I do
um when my my nag cannot get the
technique going what should I do Dave
you're saying don't shut him down okay I
would say that you can do one of two
things and from there it depends on your
skill even these one of two things it
depends on your skill okay I would say
at a bare minimum if you are somebody
who
stilled my definition of that means that
you have some internal
aspects you generate your own t you can
generate your own tanden just standing
here there's enough yongi and a constant
descent that you can Bounce It Back Off
the Earth to form your own in lower
tanden hence standing meditations hence
Zen there's no UK pushing on you to
generate that y aspect you guys
understand that okay so so I don't need
the Naga to push back on me to generate
my own
tandent it's a simple fact you guys
understand that if I can generate it by
myself in a standing
meditation I don't need her to generate
it for me I have generated it here and I
have connected to hers do you see okay
so I do that got it now she's going to
move let's let's stick with the order
okay she's going to move and you can see
here as she goes she does not have my
Center she's in my wrist okay do the
same exact thing again she's in my wrist
and you can see it right there you see
that if you go back and one of the
errors that I said is that you move with
your arm only do you see that so we're
going to for you do it again look at my
wrist okay now look at her arm and you
see that her arm moves moves and only
her arms moving they say that though
there's no weight
shifting gra there's no weight shifting
you see look at my body the arm has not
moved in the shoulder socket it's not
doing that my body is moving body is
moving and I move that body move that
body my arm does not feel this way does
not go like this was your arm
again do you see
okay so she's not going to ever move my
center but I can put my Center just like
I can put my Center in this move I can
put my Center in any moves so I move my
body and I still have her
Center do you guys see that I don't stay
here I know the
pattern I keep my Center go back I
engage I find my Center I find her
Center and I move into my Center
which I'm now in her Center okay you
feel that way okay okay she's going to
go on I keep now stay there she's in
this
hand a little bit earlier take the elbow
hand off I'm in that Center still on
that hand
watch
Center Center she goes to that Hand
Center you see center now in the two
hands you feel that
so I'm doing this bo bo one two both
hands she goes keep my Center same thing
stay there please stay there go stay
where you are engage okay and you can
see I'm in her Center in her Center and
I'm developing her Center as we're going
along she goes one I'm down same thing
you're going to tap or what you going to
do it or what there I have her Center
boom I going did not do that you do you
not going to shut her
down let's do eight in a row really
quickly
one come on let's go
two
four
[Music]
six
seven
he that's the UK who's not resisting but
also not Center
engaging
eight
finish your
Technique
down
three
four
five
six
down
seven
eight what did you notice between the
two
sets just describe anything I'm
exhausted after the second set was uh
took a lot more out of
me um a lot more of my whole body's
engaged feel it did you notice how you
didn't want to pin you wanted it over
you could tell that thing's
heavy don't go anymore you think there's
way more effort in that second step is
it
visible okay
so here I am I'm working my own
Tad but I'm also yes engaging her she's
having to use more of her body to get
the same thing done if you pay
attention she has to ground more too CU
I'm helping you ground so in the same
way as a I'm a
UK and you go and if you pay attention
stay there
please it's our three legs are there I'm
grounding you go back to here and you
pay attention
start I'm going to ground you feel your
feet there you see that not here
not
here I go ahead and I ground you and now
I'm going to ground you the whole time
okay that's what I'm trying to do so
let's do this first thing a skilled UK
should do okay you build the tonden iy
okay let's try that go okay you can say
seated all right so we had a question in
this little break uh one of our
intermediate dasi asked the question I'm
finding a hard time keeping the tonden
field as we're going again go back to
how I introduced this if the person is
skilled if you're a skilled UK and I
Define that that you can generate the
tonden field within a standing
meditation without any young aspect
being uh delivered per prescription by
UK okay that is who is skilled so I
called you intermediate intermediate
that means you don't have that skill yet
okay but if you did have that skill and
you're not doing ukemi this way and
here's why I tell you this is the bare
minimum of how you should be training as
a skilled UK we already defined skilled
you can manifest your own lower tonden
field without the Yang aspect delivered
by
UK if you can do that and you only do it
as Naga you're wasting 50% of your
training time in developing the
necessary energetic skills the necessary
uh alchemical skills you're only
developing them as
Naga and then you stop developing those
skills by what shutting them
down this is this is a waste of time so
hence if I am skilled as UK but my Naga
is not skilled such that I
cannot perform the keyhold waza as
described in part three of this latest
Series in the podcast then this is the
bare minimum of how you should be
training okay you should constantly be
doing this at a minimum as a skilled UK
working with an unskilled nogget
okay in some ways I am teaching her the
feeling of groundedness do you see
because I grounded her feet and in some
ways I am teaching her the fullness of
the tanden okay but I'm telling you
right now the UK the nag who is at your
level of training will not have the
sensitivity to do to feel those things
they don't feel it what they feel is
exactly what she felt I'm tired I'm much
more tired I feel like I'm using my
whole body but they they will not feel
the expansion and the fullness and they
will not feel the groundedness of their
feet in any way that they can now
duplicate it okay but it starts to move
you into the ballp part and that at its
best is the the most you're doing as a
UK for your net everything else is left
up to the teacher okay all right
now if you want wanted to and again I I
teach my as I was telling you guys at
the beginning of this class I teach my
own Sons that's all you do
okay um and I mentioned that right a
father would want the best for his son
right but I'm telling you all that do
you see that but it should say something
if that's what is that's what he's
telling his kids let me do that okay but
sometimes especially as the teacher
I do the following okay and uh let's
see if we get this
going so again I think you should be in
a teacher
role so as we watched his uh technique
you can see he does not know the
architectural uh design for Iko M did
you guys all see that okay he has a
different footwork got it and uh it lost
him in the end he did some cun naga in
the middle of that which was crazy right
okay so what I can do
now is from the grounded this I can make
it where he has to follow the path of
lease resistance and I will guide him
that way into the proper technique and I
can combine that with verbal cues
because people learn differently some
people learn by feeling some people
learn by hearing you get it some people
learn by seeing and as I'm touching him
I will feel which way he's
learning uh because I will feel how his
body responds to the cues that are given
to him okay so I could take this Desi
and we would do drills half mooning to
learn they eat your footwork do you get
it you could do it just like that
or you
could teach him the technique so there
we are you feel it okay I do
everything's going to be the same but
he's going to
go and you see his foot project
out I project his foot out because put
that foot back where you are and he's
his m is wrong do you see so boom I
project his foot out because he's
supposed to be in this footwork right
okay but I didn't resist him I moved him
into the footwork he now
continues we're going to do a
moted this
way
so go let's so let's watch that go back
go back he's trying to do Ura right so
try to
do and I'm moving him the other way okay
in Step here cool watch I'm bring him
around and I'll bring him
down we'll do that side
again
cool he fixed it on his
own
cool he look how he's going over
here wrong place go
back
back put this foot in the
back watch what I'm going to do with my
body I'm going to give more of a opening
you see go back I go like this it
inspires him to go around me go
back I'll give the opening and pull him
into the
movement so this would
be the most
I would ever
correct
a UK a nag as UK but you could
see the level of skill I want that foot
to move that foot moves do you see that
I don't want him to step that way so his
pull I redirect it back into a Mot it's
not that I'm resisting do you get that
he he was trying to step back I just
brought it back around do you see
that there the reason I would
say the
most obviously I'm correcting
him and the reason I put it in the ball
heart for the extremely highly
skilled is because it's a kind of
Gaza do you see it you don't know what
they're going to do but you know where
you want him to go so he wanted that my
I want you back a little he wants to go
around I want you to come around the
front side of me do do you see that so
it's a kind of
guaza why am I saying maybe that because
it's not
Kona do do you see that you you have
to
um have a a little bit more of your ego
tripartite mind in there because your
destination is picked because it's not
holy K Wasa it's not holy Gaza do do you
understand that and so you it would be
like zazen the state of zazen where your
ego tripartite mind is going on and off
do you see that and
[Music]
I there's better ways of teaching him
without practicing it that's not my
problem do you know what I mean turning
my ego triarte mind on is not my problem
that's none of our problem do you see
but I might want to play with it as I'm
just going to let's see if I could move
Sarah's foot but it's quite self-serving
in my opinion do you do you get it
because it's more efficient to teach him
through micro drills and instruction and
demonstration than it is to manipulate
his foot manipulate him around cuz I
guarantee you it didn't corre it would
correct him even less than the micr
drills did okay because it's not he's
not operating at a level Beyond his ego
tripartite mind that's not how he's
train he's not training at that level
yet and all of those projections were
outside of his EG tripartite mind so
they did not register
at all on where do I move how do I move
so the next UK he goes with uh who
doesn't do that or is less skilled than
him he can't he won't be able to put it
to you so he won't find the power okay
uh but it is something I do every once
in a while uh to help you guys do it
usually if you pay attention I do it in
Gaza so we're doing Gaza and you're not
finding anything do you see and then
I'll move you like that into the
technique I can feel you wanting so I
move you in there to find that so go
back and watch our gwet videos where I'm
not just demonstrating it but I'm
actually training it and you'll see me
moving you to where I know you want to
go but you can't figure out how to get
there
okay